this Bitcoin look is patent leather for
my impending patent and it going buddy
yawns okay can I help you with something
try to keep up Fred
meet phone mix we've got the Ross
we got the Rachel going over here to the
Lincoln Oh classic Abbi no Jaime this
time I myself don't ask favors bud
these are phone cases Brad I'm sorry I
can't go any slower okay phone wigs are
a 21st century cultural phenomenon an
age where technology divides and
isolates us phone wings give us the
chance to feel comforted to connect and
humanize and that didn't mean that is
the basis of my witness witness my
witness witness
[Music]
hey hey we found a switcher Oh someone
saw it on the news and brought it back
thank you so much I'm so sorry I've been
telling everyone I pass by to boycott
this place you did what
no kidding thank you
please don't come back here you're a bad
person
hey sir you should have this what is
this it's a sweatshirt it's actually a
vintage sweatshirt with like the perfect
amount of where'sa mica I don't want
this I went to RISD it's too hot
out here I can't wear synthetics okay
oh I am I am sorry and um great I'm
sorry
okay you found your Bitcoin number on an
old fruit by the foot job that you
remember that I gave you for a waka
flocka flame ticket ja and you want to
cash off that money today to get a
patent for these phone wigs
you got finally it took long enough my
Brad now give me the loot give me the
loot you could learn how to communicate
better good anyway
eight thousand two hundred and
sixty-five dollars has been transferred
to your account
what are you 26 now I'm 27 and what are
you like a hot ripped uncut 50 year old
47 okay fine I just mean that we had sex
when I was 21 that's gross
you grow up maybe okay that's fair but I
was going through a divorce then and I
was in a really insecure place and
having sex with someone younger boosted
my self-esteem a little well I mean I'm
in an age-appropriate relationship now
that's really good good for you yeah her
name's Marie and I think you'd really
like her okay that's cool you're cool
you're good it was great to see you
great so long phone links
yes what are we protesting today huh
Bitcoin because it's kinda yours but do
but it's paperless oh you know the coin
has to be mined by thousands of
computers 24/7 it's a huge waste of
energy because of all the servers it's
using and it's the pedophiles currency
of fueling the child sex trade industry
and dominating the illegal arms world
well you can thank Bitcoin for that
because it's contributing to climate
change so you're feeling the effects
[Applause]
okay so be honest
do I have to donate that $8,000
I know bitcoin is evil but it's like no
more evil than paper money it's like I
was like what about eating meat the meat
industry is the biggest contributor to
climate change I mean way more than
Bitcoin do you know that the fashion
industry burns the remainder of its
clothes at the end of every season to
retain its value
mountains of clothes on fire yeah not to
mention that it's all made by little
children you know recycling folks are
you really scrubbing out my food on
containers and peeling the labels off
and melting the plastic down to reform
them into new Adhan containers oh dude
garbage island is real mother earth is
like yeah
why has the news not covering this 24/7
don't even get me started on the news
the news is like what news is like hey
guys hey maybe focus on like important
issues like like recycling instead of
latching on to some stupid but really
understandable layout issues and flyers
like wait yeah what also we are being
listened to all of the timing yeah that
we do on social media for free we pay
for through our experience we're just
data whoa I feel so much better thank
you so much oh my god
[Music]